[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Chef Hewitt,
executive chef
of Chartreuse Kitchen
and Cocktails in Midtown,
and Michelle, farm manager?
Is that correct?
Cool-- at Recovery Park Farms.
I think I told do this, but
I grew up on a farm in Ohio.
Did I mention that?
MICHELLE LUTZ: No, you didn't.
That's great.
SPEAKER: Yeah, a farm boy.
Yep.
You guys were both
born in Detroit
and have spent most of your
lives working in southeastern
Michigan, which is fantastic.
We'll hear a lot
more about that.
You guys both have incredibly
interesting stories
individually, which we'll
definitely hear today,
but I think what's
really interesting is
how you guys have kind
of brought your careers
and businesses together.
So again, we'll talk about
each individually, and then
kind of bring things
together once we
grab that snack in between.
So Google Detroit,
please welcome
Chef Doug Hewitt
and Michelle Lutz.
[APPLAUSE]
Awesome.
So Chef, let's start with you.
We've had a lot of
interesting chefs
join us in this office
throughout the Talks at Google
program nationally.
You saw a few that have been to
our office just a minute ago.
I don't know.
I feel like a big hit is
always just kind of hearing
a little bit about your
background and, I guess,
how you got into
this passion for food
and what really kind of
set you on your path,
and maybe we'll start there.
DOUGLAS HEWITT: Yeah,
you want the long version
or the short version?
SPEAKER: Well, we've got
about 50 minutes now.
You can run with it however you
like within that time frame.
DOUGLAS HEWITT: Yeah, so
pretty much, like you said,
I grew up in Detroit--
not my whole life, but
my dad was a city cop.
So when he retired, we
moved out to a little town
called Howell,
which, at the time,
was literally like moving--
like I felt like to Nebraska.
You know what I mean?
There was like
one traffic light,
nothing but corn and stuff
like that, so it was crazy.
So that's kind of like
culture shock for me.
And the first part, first
time seeing a snake, frog,
and that kind of stuff.
So just different
life than the city.
But I loved it, so I got kind
of involved in farms and and
playing golf, and
like most chefs,
I started washing
dishes at a golf course
to play for free
with all my buddies.
And then it was
kind of something
that I took interest in,
and I was big into sports,
but I just sucked at them all.
So there was no
career for me in any
of the sports I
really wanted to play,
so I, kind of being the
competitive guy that I am,
I kind of like found
sort of a niche
in this competitive
environment of food.
And then I decided to
give school a shot.
And then the passion started
to grow and grow and grow.
And that's pretty much the
short side of things there.
SPEAKER: So what was your
first kind of soiree into--
you mentioned the country
club or the golf course,
working there, getting
the free access
to golf, which I think
some people in the audience
actually do that right now.
They wash dishes for free golf.
We're a big golf office here.
What was your first
kind of official move
into preparing food and
working within the kitchen?
How is that process
kind of from the back
of the kitchen into starting to
actually cook food and prepare
food?
DOUGLAS HEWITT: Yeah, so being--
the way it was set up,
the dishwasher line
was like sort of--
like behind me was
the hot line, so a lot
of swearing and flames and
communication and just a lot
of controlled chaos,
I think, is the term
that a lot of
industry people use.
So it was just something I
thought I had to be a part of.
And luckily for me,
I got an opportunity.
The club we were at,
you went from dishwasher
to prep cook, which
means you just peeled
carrots all day for weddings
and stuff like that.
I got to skip that
point to start
doing dinner service on the
grill with some guys that
brought me up and really showed
me what they knew at the time.
And at the time, I
thought I knew a lot.
But then sort of culinary school
sort of bored me in a way.
I think the first time,
I was like, oh, no.
I took a job at the
casino in Mount Pleasant.
And that was my first
experience of just ass whooping
every night, four
cigarettes in the car
before I walked in,
just like freaking out.
And that was the
first moment where
I had to decide whether if
I'm going to accept this pain,
If I'm going to do this, I'm
not going to be miserable
when a table walks
in at 10 o'clock,
and I want to get out of here.
So it's kind of my--
like my come to Jesus that
I had with myself was, look,
if I'm going to
do this, I'm going
to have a better outlook on it.
I'm going to have a
better attitude about it.
These things are
going to happen.
And from that point forward
is when I started to--
all the things that
were happening-- there
is information around
us all the time.
That was the first time
I was able to start
absorbing everything.
And from that point on, I
was on quite a fast pace
at being my own chef
from that point on.
First, I had my first
executive chef job
at 23 coming back
from that place,
and I haven't looked back since.
I've had my own
restaurant since,
and I've been pretty fortunate.
SPEAKER: That's awesome.
I think what-- and
you touched on it--
I'd like to go into your first
kind of restaurant experience.
I know you were
working in Dexter
for several years with
your own kind of spot,
again, starting at age
23, which is incredible.
Before we skip over the
part that you teased a bit,
I think one thing we'd like to
hear here, and a lot of folks
do, is you go to a restaurant,
and it's always so calm
and collected in the front.
The dining area is
so quiet and chill,
and everyone's having
a nice kind of time.
All of the chefs that
we have come in always
tell us these crazy stories
of knives being thrown
and people lighting things
on fire in the back.
What's that contrast like?
How do you kind of learn--
like you just mentioned
smoking four cigarettes
before you go in just to
kind of calm your nerves.
Like it's crazy kind
of the ecosystem
that occurs behind the
doors of the kitchen.
DOUGLAS HEWITT: Yeah, there is--
it's weird.
That was kind of my previous
life, but even at times now,
I mean if anyone's
been to Chartreuse,
you know that we are very
much out in the open.
So we're basically--
people are sometimes
dining right in
front of our paths,
where the food is coming.
So the Yelpers are
controlled these days,
or I really hope
to control them.
But yeah, it's true.
In the back of the house,
we're a different bunch.
And there's-- in the
back of the house,
you see just all sorts
of different individuals,
whether it be background or how
they grew up or just flat out
who they really are, probably
people you would never be
friends with if it were a social
setting or maybe a high school
setting or even just
neighbor setting.
Some of my closest
friends to this day
are people that we have
zero in common outside
of our passion for this and foul
language and stuff like that,
but you really start to--
you really start to see
who really people are.
And food is a way to
bring everybody together,
so outside of--
there have been some
outbursts, I'm sure.
But I've never dodged a knife or
almost been hit with a potato,
or I've got plenty of burns
from people burning me,
not intentionally, or
maybe intentionally.
I'm not really sure.
But yeah, it is a
rowdy environment,
but I think as long as
it's a positive rowdiness,
I think it almost has to happen.
You know I mean?
Think about before a football
team takes the field,
or there's these pep
talks and stuff like that.
You have to really keep
your energy level high,
because throughout
the dinner service,
you never really know
what's going to happen.
You need to be alert.
You need to be ready
for the unthinkable.
So I think there has to be
this level of energy that
is probably much different
than any other job setting.
And A, part of it
is personality,
but the other half is because we
need to keep that energy going.
SPEAKER: Yeah, absolutely.
And a lot of chefs
that come in--
and you mentioned it too-- talk
about the competitive nature,
too.
There's a challenge every
night to making sure
that things go as
flawlessly as possible,
or at least if they
don't go flawlessly,
that the people in the dining
room don't know about it.
How did you handle
that type of pressure?
So you mentioned your first
full ownership of a kitchen
was at the age of 23, and
you spent a lot of time
in that particular kitchen.
How did you handle that
at such a young age?
I mean at the time, you probably
felt like you had the world,
but looking back,
that's a young age
to have all of that
pressure on you.
DOUGLAS HEWITT: Yeah, it is.
And that's really where a lot
of the outbursts and stuff come
from is when the pressure starts
to build and build and build,
and even now, 13 years later,
the pressure's still there.
And I think that's really
when people start cracking is
there's just so much pressure.
The people around you, they have
to sort of feel that pressure.
But they're not in
that position to handle
the pressure for a reason.
You need them to all be like
tools to sort of relieve
the pressure.
Perhaps they go on to be
executive chefs and that,
but a lot of times--
so at a young age,
first of all, I
was lucky to hire some pretty
awesome people, some who
are with me still to this day.
And my sous chef's
like 31 years old,
and he's been with me
for I think 11 years.
So pretty awesome.
But I just try to do it--
at that age, there is some ego.
You think you've got
to figure it out.
It's pretty fucking bad ass.
I am, you know.
But at the same time,
you're doing it with them.
Being that age and
being the chef,
it's not like, all
right, guys, mop it up.
I'm out of here.
I drive a POS car
just like they do.
We're all broke.
You know what I mean?
So there was none
of that ego, and I
think that's how we
kind of did it together.
We all came in at the same time.
We left at the same time.
And that was an environment
that they really wanted.
We'd all been to
culinary school.
We've all worked for
other guys, and it
was sort of that-- there
was sort of that this
is the way the industry works.
As I come in, Chef
bounces or all this stuff,
and then I'm sort of left
to pick up all the pieces.
And it wasn't like that for us.
So we sort of created
this restaurant nucleus,
and many of us are still at it
to this day, if not with me,
doing other kitchens.
So I think that
was how we did it.
We burnt a lot of food.
We broke a lot of sauces.
We burnt a lot of sausage.
Our first time in charcuterie,
we failed miserably.
Our prosciutto was always
molded the first couple times.
It was like we figured
it out together.
So that's how it was.
So we basically just
created a family,
and we stuck together for
10 years in Ann Arbor,
and then four of us are
still in Detroit now, so.
SPEAKER: Can you talk
about that transition now
from running a kitchen in
Dexter to moving things
into downtown Detroit, midtown
Detroit with Chartreuse?
And I think-- and correct
me if I have this wrong--
but I think there's a connection
to one of the chefs we've
already had in, James
Rigato, in terms
of making an introduction.
I'd love to hear about that.
DOUGLAS HEWITT: Yeah,
so it's no secret James
and I are really good friends.
We have been for
a very long time.
We both went to the
same high school,
grew up in the same town.
Brendon Edwards, too, actually.
He's a Howell guy, too.
SPEAKER: All the
good chefs in Detroit
are coming from
Howell, in case you're
looking for the next big thing.
Let's go check out Howell.
DOUGLAS HEWITT: It's
like, what's in the water?
Like nothing.
I don't know if it was a lack
of salt growing up or what,
but we all had to get out of
here and do something else.
SPEAKER: James didn't
have the best things
to say about Howell either.
He was not very
uncensored about it,
so good chefs that
get out of there.
DOUGLAS HEWITT: Well, unlike
James, I like Howell--
SPEAKER: That's
good to know, good.
DOUGLAS HEWITT: --because
I still live there.
That's where my house
is, so for now, I
have to say things like that.
But yeah, I think if any of
you sat in the room with James,
you already know there's a huge
difference between James and I.
But there is a common bond, and
that's our friendship and food.
So from Ann Arbor, or Dexter--
excuse me-- come to Detroit.
So James is one of my
best customers out there,
and he kind of knew Doug food.
Like James has
probably eaten my food
more than he's eaten
any other food,
and I'm thankful for that,
because because of that,
a lot of opportunity
has happened.
So he's the one that kind
of put Sandy and I together.
If you don't know,
Sandy Levine and I
are partners at Chartreuse.
He owns the Oakland
Ferndale, so sort
of like a speakeasy
cocktail bar kind of thing.
And he put us in contact
in saying he really wanted
to get back in the restaurant.
I really wanted to get back to
Detroit, and within two weeks,
we signed a lease.
And nine months from that point
on, we opened a restaurant.
And it's been pretty awesome.
SPEAKER: How did you guys go
about the conceptualization
of what Chartreuse has become?
Was there a clear vision right
up front when you sat down
to speak with Sandy, or did
it take some time to develop?
DOUGLAS HEWITT: Yeah, I think--
SPEAKER: Was it going to be
like a chicken wing restaurant,
and then all of a sudden--
DOUGLAS HEWITT: No, no, no, no.
No, it was very important
to me that I was
able to do what I'm good at.
Obviously, we all want
to be comfortable,
and especially when we're doing
such pride in stepping out
of our comfort
zone, you really got
to bring something
you're familiar with.
So it was really important to
me that I kept that sort of--
I don't want to beat farm
to table in the face.
It's becoming sort
of a cliche in a way.
But it was really
important to me
that I could have the
relationship with the food,
I could touch the food.
We wanted a smaller joint,
because I don't really
want to be a clipboard guy.
So I really want to
touch food every day.
I want to be a part
of what we're doing.
So because of that-- and
obviously, being in Dexter,
really, I was really
starting to get
a pretty good base of Dexter
farmers that I was using.
And that was really
addicting to me.
And being in Detroit, there's--
I'm able to get to so many
more places than Dexter.
So that was really cool for me.
And then obviously, Chartreuse
being Sandy's favorite liqueur,
but you'll hear kind of
the story about Chartreuse
here in a little bit.
But we thought that it kind
of fit both of our angles.
So really, that was the
most important thing.
And that's really
what Sandy wanted too.
We wanted a simple restaurant,
and that's really all it is.
I mean it's a very casual place.
If you've been there, you
know, there is no dress code.
I mean you could come in wearing
anything, doing anything.
It really doesn't matter.
We're happy to have people come
and enjoy what we're up to.
And that was really it.
We wanted to feel like we were
inviting people into our house,
and I think you'll see
that with the build out.
Kind of necessity, too.
Don't get me wrong.
But because of that build out,
before we signed the lease,
we decided, all right, this
is how it's going to be.
We want people coming
into our living rooms,
our home, hide from
nothing, simplicity,
let food be what it is,
and see what happens.
And the first year
was pretty awesome.
We were able to win a
few awards and honeymoon
the second time, which was
really good business-wise.
And from that point on,
we haven't looked back.
SPEAKER: That's awesome.
And kind of starting to
transition a little bit
into Michelle and her story,
as we kind of converge
these things, so if you guys
haven't been to Chartreuse,
vegetables play a massive
role in what you guys produce
and the plates that you guys
bring to the table every night.
I read a free press article,
"Detroit Free Press"
article, that described
you as a vegetable wizard.
I don't know if you put
that on your business card,
but if you don't, you
should, because it's awesome.
One thing-- and again, correct
me if I'm wrong in this--
that Chartreuse is
a quaint kitchen,
and there was not enough room
for a big walk-in freezer
or cooler.
And as such-- and again, with
this background of vegetables,
you weren't able to freeze
vegetables or keep them cold.
So as they come in
fresh, you basically
turn them around and put
them right back on the table.
So there's no freezing.
There's no preservation from
kind of that type of concept.
So the vegetables in
the food that you get
are incredibly
fresh, even compared
to a lot of other restaurants
that say they do it fresh.
A lot of times, they're
freezing the vegetables.
So I think that's a
really cool kind of aspect
of the way you guys do things.
It's kind of a
necessity based on size,
but it's also a big plus as well
and what's got you guys a lot
of recognition.
DOUGLAS HEWITT: Yeah,
sometimes less is more.
Sometimes your biggest
challenge ends up
being your biggest
asset or your ally.
It was very terrifying at
Chartreuse, not, for one,
having just--
you can't get three
guys in a line.
That's unheard of.
When you're feeding
over 1,000 people
a week with two
guys on the line,
and then, obviously, the garde
manger and stuff like that.
It was very terrifying.
I didn't really think--
I didn't really know how we were
going to actually pull it off.
We got kind of lucky, you know.
So we found that, all
right, well, let's try
to buy as much-- as fresh as
we can, as much as we can,
meaning on days to days to days,
and it just kind of worked out.
And we do a lot of
things raw, and maybe it
was good timing, too.
I don't know.
It felt like we were kind of
composing vegetable plates
that other people weren't
doing, which you see
at a lot of restaurants now.
Not that we're cutting edge or
we started a trend or anything.
I just think that we kind of
were the first ones there.
So we got a lot of hype for
vegetables, and we should have.
There's a lot of great
farmers like Michelle
doing unbelievable work, and we
just wanted to showcase them.
Add a little salt to a tomato
that was picked that morning.
You don't need a chef
to tell you that's good.
You know what I mean?
So it's just really good
food that we try to not ruin.
And because of it, we
were really successful.
But yeah, the size
of the kitchen
really ended up turning out to
be sort of our secret weapon.
It's really hard to overthink
things if you can't.
So that's kind of how it was.
SPEAKER: That's fantastic.
Good segue over to Michelle now.
We'd love to hear a little
bit about your position.
And Recovery Park now--
for those of you
that don't know--
was founded in 2010, so
about seven years ago.
And the farm aspect was
brought in a few years later.
This was-- timing, Chef.
You mentioned timing is a
key concept around Detroit.
Timing is everything.
10 years ago, you didn't
want to be in Detroit.
Now everyone wants
to be in Detroit,
and timing is a big thing.
For Recovery Park,
I think the timing
was excellent in terms
of when it was developed
and what it does.
So Michelle, maybe you
can tell us a little bit--
excuse me-- a little bit about
Recovery Park and Recovery Park
Farms and what that
concept is and how
it was established and built
within downtown Detroit.
MICHELLE LUTZ: So believe it
or not, the idea goes back
to 2008, where our president
and CEO, a gentleman
by the name of Gary
Wozniak, was helping
to right size an organization,
SHAR, Self Help Addiction
Rehabilitation.
And the idea was, how
do you help people
that are trying to stay clean?
And finding employment,
but meaningful employment
was one of the top conversations
that kept coming up.
So I'll never forget the day
that I got a call from him,
and I was--
I had left Detroit in '94 and
bought an 80-acre farm in Yale.
Kind of Doug's and I's
stories are so similar.
It's kind of crazy.
So I go up to this town in
Yale, and I buy an 80-acre farm.
I have no idea what I'm doing.
I'm not born in a
farming background,
nor have any idea
what I'm about to do.
But by 2008, I have
had a little success
and started to
learn a few things.
And he approached me
and said, what do you
think about the idea
of farming in Detroit?
I said, well, I love the idea.
He said, what do you
think about the idea
about employing
people who are trying
to rehabilitate their lives?
And I said, well, it's
a phenomenal idea,
because to me, agriculture
is very therapeutic.
There's so much that you can
work out and leave in the soil
if you're having a bad day.
And it's something that you
can see the direct impact.
You see the results
of what you work on.
So I think for that, it
can be very challenging,
but it can also be
extremely rewarding.
And at that time,
it was just an idea.
And he said, would you help?
And I said, absolutely,
however I can help.
So my help along
the years was really
kind of like they would throw
out an idea, a business plan.
What do you think
if we just did that?
And I'd say, oh,
that's a horrible idea.
Don't do that.
Well, what should we do?
And I kind of just kept saying,
look at what the market needs.
Try to address.
And my heart was
still in the city.
People would always say
to us, why can't you
just do this down in Detroit?
And I said, well, give us
80 acres, and we'll do it.
But back then, that
wasn't happening.
With the administration
that we had, it wasn't--
no one was willing to do that.
But our connection to the
city was still very clear.
I mean we had CSA drop-offs,
like when Avalon first opened,
that was our first CSA
drop-off way back then.
We had CSA drop-offs
on Rosa Parks,
and we fed shelters and
firehouses, and so very much
still, hitting the city
with our food twice a week.
And the funny thing
for me, though,
is I never thought
that it would lead
to a career with Recovery Park.
I never thought that I would
actually be farming for them.
So life happens, and I
left my farm in 2011,
and I did a project over for
Henry Ford Health Care Systems.
I opened up a greenhouse behind
their West Bloomfield facility.
And I was having a lot of
fun over there doing that.
And then Gary came to
me in 2013, and he said,
we're at the point
now that we've
got to start proving out the
whole ag part of the business.
And would you come
and farm for us?
Will you do a pilot
project for us?
And I had 100%
confidence in the idea
that we would grow specialty
produce and grow it
locally and get it to
chefs as fresh as possible.
So I was like, sure.
So the very first thing
that we did in 2014
is we built a high
tunnel, which is
one of those structures
over there on the wall.
We call them high tunnels.
We built one in a parking lot
off of East Grand Boulevard
and made brazed beds in it
and filled it with compost
that we brought in.
And that was the very
first year that we grew.
And to no surprise,
it was working.
People want--
finally, it's the time
where chefs are so prone to
say, yes, this is what we want.
We want to know the grower.
We want to be able to
go and see the food
and have a relationship
and talk about what
I wanted to see on the menu.
And we tried to do
this 10 years ago.
I mean I remember
when I first started
trying to sell to shops.
It was like, what?
What are you talking about?
No, it's got to
come through Cisco.
It's got to come
through US Foods.
We can't cut you a check.
It's got to go.
I mean it was such a
complicated ordeal.
So to start doing that was--
by 2014, what I'm trying to
say, I had a lot of confidence,
that the time was--
we had enough chefs
out there that
were ready to do
this, ready to have
you deliver a box of produce
and make something today.
And then if you brought
them something else
excellent two days
from then, they
were willing to change that.
A small grower
locally isn't going
to be-- we're never
going to supply a Subway.
We're never going to
have 500 cases of five
by fives at some price that you
can't make up or pay a living
wage off of.
It's never going to happen.
So you kind of got to
go in a direction that
will take your business
to where it needs to go.
So we've done a few
years of pilot projects,
waiting for the city to give
us some land that we can really
execute our idea.
And in the fall
of 2015, the mayor
announced that the
land bank would
allow us to lease some property
over in the neighborhood
that we're at right now.
We're on the east side,
Chene and Ferry area,
to give you some kind of--
we're a couple of miles away
from Eastern Market to
give you some idea of where
we're located.
So it's a very--
it's a very vacant neighborhood.
What I know about is
that in the 1950s,
there was 100,000 jobs
within walking distance
of that neighborhood.
2,500 people lived
on a 22-block radius.
There are now 17 residents
in that neighborhood.
So Recovery Park
caretakes that 22 blocks.
What does that look like?
Any land that
belongs to the city--
we clean up blight.
We make sure that any dumping
that goes on gets cleaned up.
We mow those grasses.
We keep it clean.
And back in October,
we started building
what we called Beta
Farm, because we still
have a lot to learn.
I'm embarrassed to tell you
guys that after 23 years
of doing this, I still
have a lot to learn.
I've never done this in this
type of environment before.
The Detroit soil has
so much to offer,
and I mean that
very sarcastically.
There's so much debris.
You know, back then, where
there was houses right there,
this is when they still
just collapsed the houses
into the basements.
So there's a lot of
fun stuff to find.
So we started building
those in October,
and it took a little
longer than it should,
like any construction project.
But we are now-- we have
eight out of seven structures
completely operational.
The only reason why the
last one isn't online
is because Monday, we
plant that with tomatoes
so that we have a
succession of crop.
And we have six farms
associates working with us.
The reason why Recovery
Park Farms exists
is because Recovery
Park, the nonprofit,
wants to create jobs for people
with barriers to employment.
But when you're a
nonprofit, you're
always looking for
funding, right?
So that can be very
unstable to people's lives
if funding runs out.
So we decided that
Recovery Park would
launch for-profit businesses,
so that way, the business can
stand on its own two
legs, and we can make sure
that people's lives are not
destabilized at any point.
So we hire people with
barriers to employment.
Our farm crew has--
none of them have
had any experience
with farming before
or growing anything.
I was so confident
in our ability
to train people that I hired
based on personality and work
ethic.
And so I'm proud to
say that it's working.
SPEAKER: That's awesome.
Thanks for the background.
I think there's a lot
of questions still
on how you guys got this
up and running, even
with that detailed description.
It's incredible what you
guys have been able to do.
Detroit's a unique canvas
for something like this,
because there's a lot
of underutilized assets.
So you've got a massive city
with a million plus people,
but a lot of empty
and vacant land.
You've got access to fresh water
with the Detroit River and Lake
St. Clair so nearby, and
you've got a wanting workforce.
You have folks that
want to work, but maybe
have had issues in the past
or have challenges with it.
So it's kind of
this really unique
coming together
of a lot of things
that make this possible,
which I think is fantastic.
Could you talk a little bit more
before we take a quick break,
and then talk about how you
guys have come together?
And you touched on it just a
minute ago about this hiring
process.
Where do you go to find
these type of employees?
What's your process for bringing
talent in and training them
and getting them ramped up
on this process of working
within Recovery Park Farms.
MICHELLE LUTZ: So I
always tell everybody
we hire the best talent, but
we're completely prepared
to work with people who have
some challenges in life.
We look within
our own community.
Hiring Detroit residents
is very important to us.
It's one of our conditions
with the city of Detroit
that such a percentage
of our workforce
are Detroit residents.
I think we have to have
61% of our workforce.
We work within the prisons.
We have a relationship with
the Michigan Department
of Corrections.
It's actually a pretty
solid relationship,
where they are even interested
in adding hydroponic growing
into some of their
training facilities
so that we can have more
of a workforce ready.
It's very important that
when people come out
of incarceration that
they have employment
and housing immediately.
So they say that a
success is somebody
who comes out of prison that
doesn't go back in two years.
You could still be
addicted to drugs.
You could be living
under an overpass.
You could be eating
out of a garbage.
That doesn't look
like success to us.
So for us, we want to make sure
that our employees, after 90
days of full time employment,
have a 100% company paid
health care.
We have someone on staff that
works with all of their needs--
transportation, housing,
reunification with family,
religion, all of those areas.
I can't even list them,
because that's really not
what my job is on the farm.
But we have somebody on
staff that does that.
As far as finding people,
we work with Michigan
Rehabilitative Services.
So we have SHAR,
that organization.
We found some of our farm
team from those organizations.
SPEAKER: And last question
before we take a quick break.
What does the future look like?
It seems like you're
getting a lot of support
from the city of Detroit.
It seems like you're finding
some really good success, so
a lot of positive momentum.
Like what do you see as
the next steps-- expansion,
just continuing to
perfect what you do?
Where do you see the vision
of Recovery Parks Farm going?
MICHELLE LUTZ: So the five-year
plan, when we get there,
is for us to have 200
employees, that we would
have 22 acres under glass.
So if you take a look at that
photo there that I have up,
that's one city block,
about three acres.
So there are eight
of those structures
up there, so we'll
have nine acres that
look something like that.
And we would have 22 acres
under glass production.
So if you can imagine
a city block but be
covered in a glass greenhouse.
In that, we would do
hydroponic growing there.
But what the coolest thing to me
about that five-year plan is it
shows that Chene Street
comes back with businesses.
It shows opportunities
for housing.
It shows opportunity for
massive community space.
It also makes sure that the
residents that live there,
we're not doing
something obnoxious
like putting a greenhouse
right next to them.
We have really
good relationships
with the neighbors
that are there,
and we've made sure that
everyone understands
we're here to help, I
think, make the neighborhood
more beautiful.
And we want people to stay.
We're not here to say,
oh, we're here now,
and we're going to take over.
Within that 22-block area,
we have ample opportunity
and space to do those
things that we want to do.
SPEAKER: I would love to hear
the story of the convergence
between the both of you, and you
guys are obviously very close.
I'm just watching
you guys interact,
and I know you guys work
together on a daily basis.
So can you talk a little
bit about the process?
And maybe, Doug, we can
start from your perspective.
You've got a
restaurant, or you're
in the process of
putting together
a restaurant in Detroit.
You're looking for
local sourcing.
How does that process
play into working
with Michelle and her team?
DOUGLAS HEWITT: Yeah, I think
we're still looking at a space,
and the place is pretty
much just a shell.
I think Michelle reached
out to me first on Facebook.
And I was like, thank god.
I've been meaning
to get a hold of you
to see if maybe
we can partner up.
I know a lot of my
friends that were
chefs in this area before me.
I would see nonstop
Michelle's this,
Michelle's-- a lot of beets
and radishes, stuff like that.
And I was like, man, that
food is just unbelievable.
So it was definitely something
I wanted to reach out
when I came down here.
It was really important to
me that I brought some farms
with me, and then I
could reach out and start
getting some even more local or
some farms that my friends were
using.
So Michelle reached out to me.
We met, I don't
know, pretty soon
after the contact was made.
And then I said, well,
like what kind of--
what do you need from me?
She wants to know what
we want to use and stuff.
And we just basically
said, I don't really care.
I just want you to
kind of bring me boxes.
And then I could kind of just--
it's kind of a mystery basket
twice a week.
You just open it up, and
you see what's in there,
and just kind of let your
imagination go a little bit.
And it made me a
better chef by far.
But really, it was that
sort of excitement.
And when we are talking
like, hey, how about we call
the dish Recovery Park?
And she was flattered
by that, too.
And I was like, sweet,
because that's really
what I want to call it.
So our opening menu had a
Recovery Park dish on the menu.
And outside of the small
transition between properties,
we've had a Recovery Park item
on the menu since day one.
And it's just been--
it's really cool.
It's farm-specific, and
not only farm-specific,
but a lot of people know--
Michelle is sort of like--
I don't know.
In our world, she's the
face of Recovery Park.
You know what I mean?
I know there's a lot of people
that really make it work, but I
felt like it was great to
pay it forward to the farm,
pay it forward to
Gary and the idea,
all the individuals
that work on the farm,
but really pay it forward
to Michelle, too, and sort of--
there's a lot more than
just cooks out there, a lot
more than just chefs.
I mean it really is a
community of diners and farmers
and brewers and distillers,
and what a powerful nucleus
we have when we
all work together.
And I think that
we're really starting
to see that work start
to show its profits.
SPEAKER: Michelle, talk about
this from your perspective.
And so it sounds like you've got
a little bit of a-- or at least
early on, you had a little
bit of a blank canvas
in terms of what Chef was
looking for in his restaurant.
And how does that play
kind of into what you
do on a daily basis in terms
of what you're deciding to grow
and harvest and how you
get it to Chartreuse
and other restaurants
that you guys work with?
And also, kind of a second
question to that too--
you guys were mentioning the
city block and the imagery
that we're looking at now.
Does all of that food go
into local restaurants,
or do you guys work with
Eastern Market or anything
like that for surplus foods
or anything like that?
Or are you guys
completely tapped out?
So sorry.
Two distinct
questions there, but I
would love to kind of get
your perspective on both.
MICHELLE LUTZ: So I've been very
fortunate to have people come
and always want to
get produce from us.
Doug was the first guy that
I went after, and I always--
I felt like I straight
up stalked him.
Not going to lie.
So you see that
you tell the story,
so it makes me not look
like a crazy person.
But when we met, I
just knew instantly
that here's a guy
that's just going
to allow me to have free
reign, and that's so powerful.
It's so reassuring.
It's so calming.
I can just do what
I love and not
have to worry about the rest.
So just to be able
to bring whatever
is that you are motivated
to do or your feeling
is at its prime,
and then deliver
that, that's pretty confident,
solid thing for a grower
not to have to worry about
hitting a certain amount
or having this week after week.
You just keep that
creativity going.
And so that was
really great for me.
For Recovery Park, from
a business perspective,
getting a branded dish on a
menu at such an important stage
of our career, of our
life was imperative.
I mean to be able to talk
to investors and funders
and say that, that
was huge for us.
And so I hope I've
thanked you for that.
I'm going to try to say this
without getting emotional here,
but when I sat down
for the soft opening,
and I saw that on the menu,
the Recovery Park dish,
I took a photo, and
I sent it to my kids.
It meant that much.
SPEAKER: That's awesome.
MICHELLE LUTZ: So thanks.
DOUGLAS HEWITT: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHELLE LUTZ:
Sorry [INAUDIBLE]..
OK, back to business.
SPEAKER: Get it out.
It's OK.
MICHELLE LUTZ: Back to business.
So all of the--
so also from a
business perspective,
we have a 100% exclusive
arrangement with [? Elbing ?]
Produce out of Eastern Market.
Once again, huge
for us, for funders,
for people who are
looking at Recovery Park.
They buy 100% of
everything we grow.
Most of that produce is
all sold right in Detroit.
It doesn't have to go far,
maybe within a 10-mile radius.
So that's how fortunate we are.
This whole thing is working.
It's the fact that I've got a
really hardworking team, people
not just on the farm, but
on the nonprofit side.
We've got great people
like Doug and other people
that want this to work.
And then we have consumers like
you guys that go out there,
so it's--
the whole thing has to
work for this to work.
So that's where all
the produce goes.
It's really-- I'm so happy
that the marketing part is not
something I have
to stress about.
I can just grow and train people
and help people build careers.
Seriously, after three years
of being with us on this farm,
the guys that we're
working with can
go anywhere and get really--
I mean I'll have to
fight to keep them.
They will be that suited to
work anywhere in the world.
So that makes me very proud.
But it's not all about business.
We have a lot for the community.
We have a decent-sized
community garden.
We're still working
on adding to that,
so we have a
giveback, so that way,
I don't have to feel bad about
everything being sold off
the farm.
SPEAKER: That's awesome.
I love this idea
of local sourcing.
Obviously, very
important to both of you
from distinct perspectives.
My last question, as we kind of
bring everything back together,
is do you think-- so
again, we talked about this
being fairly unique to Detroit.
Do you think
something like this is
able to be repeated in other
cities or other communities?
We've got some unique physical
aspects in the city of Detroit
that allow something
like this to happen--
proximity to a major
city, proximity to--
specific timing and kind of
the renaissance of Detroit.
Is this something that's just
localized to being something
that can work in
Detroit, or do you guys
see something like this being
replicable outside of the city?
MICHELLE LUTZ: I might
take a stab at that,
because I certainly hope so.
I've dedicated the last
23 years of my life
to helping to build and
strengthen local food systems.
It is imperative
that you have that.
So anywhere in the
world, having food
right there in your
community is so important.
I look at how we've
handled natural disasters.
I look at how just when
we had the power outage,
and there was no food coming in.
We cannot be dependent on
other people feeding us.
We have to have these
type of relationships.
This is the only way it works.
An operation like ours could
not pay people a living wage
and have health care benefits.
If I had to do straight
up market pricing,
compete with large farms in
Mexico that pay people $2
a week, that system is broken.
It does not work.
It's heavy on
chemicals, and I'm not
going to get into all of that.
But if you really want to have a
strong local food system, this,
all of this-- consumers,
chefs, growers--
it all has to work.
And I'm damn proud
of what Detroit
is doing in that
element, and I'm
happy that we have as many
outstanding growers that we
have, and once again, chefs that
are taking advantage of that.
To me, I love when we have
visitors from out of town.
We had a group in from
Paris about a month ago,
and they were like, this
has to happen in Paris.
You have to come.
I was like, no, I still
got work over here to do.
But it's great to see how people
visit something like that,
and they feel instantly
that it can be duplicated.
And to me, that's a great thing.
Niagara's talked
to Recovery Park.
I mean there's been other cities
that have come in and said,
once you get this going,
but we've got a lot of it
still to figure out.
SPEAKER: Sure.
That's a great
foundation, and it's nice
when people are looking
to a city like Detroit
for opportunity and
to replicate things.
Any last thoughts,
Chef, on your side
in terms of kind
of sustainability
of this and kind
of what it looks
like for you moving forward?
DOUGLAS HEWITT: Yeah, I
mean when it comes down
to other cities being able to
duplicate exactly what we're
up to, I highly doubt it.
Some of the unfortunate parts
are our fortune, really,
being able to go
into neighborhoods,
and some cities
don't have that much.
But really what
we have, I think,
is Detroit as a whole is sort
of a very proud community.
And food is sort of--
I think food is sort of at the
forefront of the new Detroit.
I hate saying new Detroit,
but how do you avoid it?
You know what I mean?
Because there is
a lot happening.
There's a lot of new stuff.
But I think with as
many chefs and how
we interact and the farming
system, and the farming
doesn't work if the
consumer doesn't want it.
Farming doesn't-- some of these
unique ingredients don't work
if nobody knows how to use them
or if people are [INAUDIBLE]
out or weird about it,
those kind of things.
So and then all of a sudden,
the brewing and the distilling,
and now all of a
sudden, we have people
that are bringing Michigan
whole animals to Detroit, where
we're starting to buy our meat.
So really, this
was sort of like--
I think Michelle's movement
was sort of the first movement
to where everyone's
like, wait a minute.
We can do a lot more
than just produce.
And I think we're starting out--
as people are starting
work together.
Go eat anywhere in town.
Go eat at Grey Ghost.
Go eat at Selden.
Go eat at Mabel Gray.
Go eat at Chartreuse.
The chances of you
eating an animal that
wasn't raised in this state
are probably not great,
outside of some fish and
maybe a couple of the more--
ducks are more harder
things to come by.
Either eat the corn bread, and
I guarantee that buttermilk
was done in Michigan.
You know what I mean?
So go eat the egg
dish, and I guarantee
there's two or three farms
that are doing the farms.
We've taken just that
twice cooked egg alone,
and then the other restaurants
are taking this small egg guy
in Mason, Michigan to
like an actual business.
It was a hobby,
him and his wife.
And then they got sick
of washing 400,000 eggs
a week by hand.
And now they have
their son moved back
to help the business.
They bought this big washer.
And we're talking about
five restaurants in Detroit,
and all of a
sudden, this guy has
a legit business moving eggs,
and we're proud to serve them.
You know what I mean?
So it really is this network
of, really, people just trying
to do the right thing.
But again, it doesn't work if
people don't buy into that.
If people don't want to know
where their food is from,
and they don't care
about sustainability
or organic practice or those
kind of things, we're screwed.
[INAUDIBLE]
You know what I mean?
So [INAUDIBLE].
By all means, [INAUDIBLE].
Because until we [INAUDIBLE].
We got to get avocados.
I want limes.
SPEAKER: Lot of pressure.
MICHELLE LUTZ: Yeah.
DOUGLAS HEWITT: So it's
not like this mission
to be 100% sustainable.
Like I had a guy in
one time that was like,
where'd you get the octopus?
St. Clair?
Dude.
MICHELLE LUTZ: Don't hate.
DOUGLAS HEWITT: I never said
we were 100% sustainable.
We're just trying-- and
everybody's that way.
We're just trying to
do our best to keep
our money in the great
state of Michigan,
especially in the
city, and start to--
you can see the change.
You can visibly
reach out and see
how your money that you spend
on tomatoes is making an impact.
It's powerful stuff.
Not a lot of people have that
opportunity [INAUDIBLE].a.a
SPEAKER: Well, Doug,
Michelle, thank
you so much for coming in
and sharing your story.
It's very
inspirational, and it's
great to see the collaboration
that you guys have performed
and some of the
sustainability that you've
created just within Detroit.
And we wish you
the best of luck.
Thank you so much, and
thank you for coming in.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]